قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان جنود
اللواء جولاني غادروا قطاع غزه لاعاره
تنظيم صفوفهم بعد تكبدهم خسائر كبيره معنا
من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس ما التفاصيل في هذا الخبر والتطور
المهم هو الحديث كما يبدو زين عن اخراج
الكتيبه رقم 13 من اللواء جولاني وسحب هذه
الكتيبه من داخل قطاع غزه بعد ان تكبدت
خسائر كبيره في الارواح منذ بدايه العمليه
البريه ونحن نتحدث عن 42 جنديا قتيلا في
هذه الكتيبه وحدها من لواء جولاني بما
فيها قائد الكتيبه الذي قتل مع عدد من
الضباط والجنود في حي الشجاعيه الاسبوع
الماضي في التفجير الذي حصل في احد
المباني داخل الحي ونحن تتحدث اذا عن
الكتيبه 13 في لواء جولاني الذي تم سحبها
بهدف انعاش الجنود واعاده ترتيب وتنظيم
صفوف هذه الكتيبه التي منيت بخسائر فادحه
بالارواح في صفوف جنودها نشير هنا ايضا
الى ان لواء جولاني نفسه تكبد خسائر فادحه
في الارواح منذ السابع من اكتوبر
فبالاضافة
داخل قطاع غزه نحن نتحدث عن 71 جنديا
وضابطا اسرائيليا في هذا اللواء الذي يعد
من الويه النخبه
في قوات المشاء الاسرائيليه الذين قتلوا
في الهجوم الكبير في السابع من اكتوبر اي
في ظرف يوم او يومين في الهجوم الكبير في
السابع والثامن من اكتوبر حيث تواصل
القتال في منطقه غلاف غزه هذا اللواء تكبد
خسائر كبيره وقتل في صفوف جنوده وضباطه
واحس 70 بالاضافه الى 42 جنديا اخر من
كتيبه رقم 13 بما فيهم القائد قائد
الكتيبه الذي كما قلت قتل في معارك حي
الشجاعيه الاسبوع الماضي لذلك تم اخراج
هذه الكتيبه من اللواء وسحبها الى داخل
اسرائيل والقنوات الاسرائيليه بثت قبل
قليل احتفالات الجنود بخروجهم من ارض
المعركه ومن ميدان المعركه وهذا يضاف ايضا
زين الى س ب ربما كتائبه اخرى من لواء
المظليين الذي يعمل في المناطق الشماليه
وفي المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه ايضا بهدف
اعاده تنظيم الصفوف وانعاش القوات من
الواضح بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يعمل على
اعاده ترتيب صفوفه وتنظيم صفوفه للمرحله
المقبله من القتال كما يبدو وهي المرحله
التي ستبدا تشهد معارك خاصه نوعيه مركزه
وليس على شاكله المعارك التي نراها في
الايام الماضيه ربما من السابق لاوانه
الحديث عن هذه المرحله لانه ربما يبدا
الحديث عنها فقط في منتصف الشهر المقبل او
في نهايه الشهر المقبل على اعتبار ان رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو قال هذا اليوم
بان القتال سوف يستمر حتى تحقيق الانتصار
على حركه حماس وتحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب
قضاء على حركه حماس عسكريا و سلطويا
واستعاده المحتجزين الاسرائ
يعني هذا الانسحاب للكاتبه 13 من اللواء
جولاني اللواء جولاني وايضا الانسحابات
الاخرى من المظليين كيف تصور كيف تقدم هل
تقدم على انه انسحاب جراء اكراهات
المعركه عفوا ام يقدم على انه اعاده
انتشار واعاده ترتيب
للاوراق هو يقدم على انه اعاده لا اعاده
تنظيم صفوف الجيش الاس اسرائيلي وانعاش
القوات في الدرجه الاولى وطبعا الحديث
ايضا عن محاوله الجيش الاسرائيلي زين وهذه
نقطه هامه جدا في تقليل اعداد الجنود
الاحتياط الذين يشاركون في العمليات
القتاليه وكما تذكر ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
استدعى من صفوف الاحتياط في الايام الاولى
للحرب حوالي
360,000 جندي وضابط وزج بهم في ارض
المعركه في قطاع غزه وزج بهم ايضا على
الحدود الشماليه هي مع لبنان التي تشهد
حتى الساعات الاخيره ضربات وهجمات من جانب
حزب الله والفصائل الفلسطينيه المقاومه في
جنوب لبنان وعندما نتحدث عن 360,000 جندي
اسرائيلي نحن نتحدث عن جنود ايه يشتغلون
ويعملون في مصالحه وفي شركات وفي تعليم
وفي طلاب جامعات وما الى ذلك وهذا له اثر
كبير جدا زين على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل تحاول ان تعيد عجله الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن
360,000 جندي هذا نحن نتحدث عن كثير من
الشركات المعطله والوظائف التي اصبحت
شاغره وما من شك في ان هذا له اثر كبير
على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي لذلك اسرائيل
ربما تسارع الان او تسابق الزمن من اجل
انهاء المرحله الاولى المتمثله بالعمليات
العسكريه الكبرى الهجمات العسكريه الكبيره
بريا وجويا ومدفعيه وبالتالي تبدا عم وهي
بدات على فكره منذ اسابيع بتقليل اعداد
جنود الاحتياط الى حد كبير لكن هاري اليوم
دانييل هجار الناطق العسكري زين وهذه نقطه
مهمه سئل عن هذه النقطه من احد الصحفيين
الاسرائيليين وقال له هل بداتم ب فعلا
بتقليل اعداد الجنود والضباط الذين من
صفوف الاحتياط وسحبهم من ارض المعركه هو
امتنع عن الاجابه عن هذا السؤال وقال انه
لا يريد ان ينشر معلومات تتعلق بامن
المعلومات وبسريه المعلومات على الملا لان
العدو يسمع كما قال في تصريحه ابدالها
يعني هل هل تستلم كتائب اخرى او قوات اخرى
محل القوات
المنسحبه هذا بالتاكيد نعم بالتاكيد كلما
سحبت اسرائيل قوات هي تدخل اي قوات اخرى
وكما تعلم ان هنالك حشود عسكريه على تقوم
قطاع غزه وفي المعسكرات الاسرائيليه وكلما
سحبوا كتائب معينه من داخل قطاع غزه
اي هم يدخلون كتائب اخرى واحيانا الكتائب
التي تخرج لعمليه الانتعاش وتنظيم الصفوف
هي تخرج ربما لساعات قليله او على الاقل
يوم واحد لا اكثر ثم تعود للمشاركه في
الجهد الحربي لذلك نحن لا نتحدث عن انسحاب
كبير او انسحاب للواء كله انما سحب ربما
تكتيكي لبعض ال الكتائب في هذا اللواء او
او ذاك ذلك ان اسرائيل كما تذكر ايضا زين
تقول بانها سوف تواصل السيطره العسكريه
على قطاع غزه حتى بعد انتهاء المعارك
الكبرى لذلك حتى اننا لسنا في مرحله
الحديث عن اعاده الانتشار بالنسبه للقوات
الاسرائيليه في مناطق عده وهذه النقطه
ايضا كما تعلم هي مطروحه في اطار ما يعرف
او او المفاوضات الدائره من اجل اتمام
صفقه جديده
لتبادل المحتجزين والاسرى الفلسطينيين
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه تريد منذ البدايه
سحب القوات الاسرائيليه الى خارج السياج
الامني وهي تريد وقفا تاما لاطلاق النار
وانهاء الحرب واسرائيل اعلنت رفضها لهذه
لهذه ال الطلبات التي قدمتها المقاومه في
هذا السياق وقالت بانها ستواصل الحرب